[Music]
good morning at 7:02 we are in Orlando
Florida we are about to go to Daytona to
our NASCAR race event today and we are
brought out today by suave big shout out
to swallow they've sent me over the
course of like the last couple of years
they've sent me so much product like
last time they gave me this paste gave
me multiple ones of these actually test
worked with SWA that it was from Tiff's
ran deals of squad and I've been using
the citrus rush shampoo this time they
sent me this deodorant which edges
applied it's not only kind of fresh hey
I think you want to be a man yeah you
want to be a suave man yeah do you need
it you do it right now or you're still
like your body hasn't kicked in yet you
kinda need deodorant okay let's do it
you're a man now buy deodorant standards
okay do you remember your last NASCAR
race yeah
was it intense was it adrenaline fueling
alright we're gonna go downstairs we're
about to get picked up by our shuttle
and we're headed out to date
[Music]
and I'm blogging alright guys we just
got to Daytona and the first thing we're
doing here is taking a ride and the pace
car and I just found out that the pace
car is the car that leads the racers
whenever there's like an accident or
like some sort of like where you're
supposed to slow down the race and be
more cautionary about something that's
happening oh it's our turn we're right
in the pace car how fast we're gonna be
going ready for this geared now sheriff
I'm actually kind of nervous too
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feel the g-force that we called I don't
know and I just not gonna like something
you would say it was so much fun one
yeah one light 115 I think the highest
that I was tracking yeah he's dead
thanks to the g-force it's like it
starts like pushing you into the seats
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're gonna be a pilot one day
I want to do exactly that
[Music]
what is this huh
the holler holler yeah we are in the
holler team trance where I like that one
it's like we're in the spaceship the
team transporter GT Motorsports has four
race teams so this is the home away from
home this is a rolling office and race
shop
all right guys they have a whole garage
up right above us the car above us right
now and they have a lot of parts where
they can actually build a secondary
guard just in case the primary car
crashes or whatever could possibly
happen you can't build a secondary show
goes on
[Music]
what I know
[Music]
all right guys the are morning happens
very very very eventful morning and I
took a ride and a pace car got to feel
like a fraction of how bad how much like
g4g fuel in a race car the NSM we walked
around the victory lane got to the
hauler I think that should be the taxi
of what it's like to be part of the
group what they seem would be deal with
and then we got to meet up with Justin
Elgar and use our race driver who's our
drive for them a route for today two
years ago when we came out into Dallas
we went to Dallas for a NASCAR race and
we met him then and catch up with him
today was really really cool now we are
at a sweet
at C Daytona Speedway and it feels very
very div for the NASCAR Xfinity series
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]